c'est une bonne mesure pour les
locataires elle fait plutôt grincer les
dents des propriétaires la loi climat et
résilience un site ces derniers à
réaliser des travaux pour accroître leur
performances énergétique trop cher pour
un quart des propriétaires qui
envisageraient de vendre on en parle
avec mon invité
bonsoir Vincent brillant vous êtes
délégué départemental de la FNAIM 37
syndicat de professionnels de
l'immobilier alors cette loi prévoit
l'interdiction progressive de mise en
location des logements classés f et g
par le diagnostic de performance
énergétique le fameux DPE le but est
d'inciter les propriétaires bailleurs à
faire des travaux vous avez consulté
vous ses propriétaires bailleurs
sont-ils prêts à faire les travaux oui
alors est-ce que c'est je reprends juste
la phrase c'est une bonne nouvelle pour
les locataires j'espère que ça le sera
je suis pas sûr que ça le sera forcément
puisque effectivement les professionnels
de l'immobilier se sont inquiétés de
savoir si les propriétaires bailleurs
avaient les moyens ou l'intention de
faire des rénovations c'est pas
forcément le cas pour la plupart d'entre
eux il y a un sondage qui a été réalisé
auprès de 500 administrateurs de bien en
France et on a 26% des propriétaires
d'ailleurs qui annoncent qu'ils veulent
vendre donc ça veut dire que
potentiellement c'est des biens qui vont
être retirés du marché locatif donc je
suis pas certain que pour les locataires
ça soit une aubaine puisque on a déjà
une tension sur le marché locatif
l'aubaine c'est qu'à terme il puisse y
avoir un accroissement de la performance
énergétique et que les passoires ces
fameuses passoires énergétiques
disparaissent du parc alors ça cette
solution n'est pas la bonne ça c'est sûr
que c'est un objectif partagé par tous
je pense que tout le monde a conscience
aujourd'hui la nécessité de corriger ce
tir après non ce qu'on pense nous
professionnelle immobilier c'est qu'il
faut accompagner les propriétaires
bailleurs par plusieurs mesures c'est
d'ailleurs ce que propose la fnaie et
puis peut-être aussi étendre cette
interdiction ou cette obligation à
l'ensemble des propriétaires parce
qu'aujourd'hui on se contente de
s'occuper des il est bien qui sont en
location mais il y a également les
résidences principales absolument ça
fait partie des mesures à la troisième
mesure de proposer par la FNM qui a été
suggéré au gouvernement c'est de dire on
se fixe un objectif minimum qui est de
la classe F pour l'ensemble des
copropriétés au premier janvier au 1er
janvier pardon 2030 donc ça fait ça ça
crée au moins une justice entre
l'ensemble des propriétaires 2030 on est
en 2022 ça fait 8 ans là l'obligation
elle commence en janvier 2023 alors
effectivement qu'est-ce qui va se passer
en janvier 2020 le 1er janvier 2023 les
biens qui sont concernés par
l'interdiction de la location ce sont
les biens qui sont classés en DPEG et
qui sont au-delà de 450 kWh par mètre
carré c'est vraiment les vrais pasteurs
thermiques
à partir de deux ans plus tard il y a
l'ensemble des DPE g donc c'est un ça
représente beaucoup et puis ensuite ça
sera le F donc on a on a effectivement
une difficulté particulière sur ce que
les copropriété parce que on sait quand
on est dans une copropriété la
difficulté c'est qu'on peut pas rénover
tout seul il faut que l'ensemble des
copropriétaires soient d'accord
[Musique]
en fait qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait il nous
reste temps pour pour accompagner au
mieux ses propriétés d'ailleurs qui est
une mesure de bon sens que propose la
FNAIM les professionnels de l'immobilier
c'est de rendre solidaire les
copropriétaires c'est-à-dire que un
copropriétaire qui est classé en G parce
qu'il est au rez-de-chaussée orienté
nord alors que son voisin qui est entre
le deuxième et le quatrième étage
orienté sud est en F il y a une forme
d'injustice alors que la construction
c'est exactement la même notre idée
c'est de rendre le DPE collectif de
l'immeuble opposable c'est-à-dire que on
arrête de se focaliser sur le député
individuel sur le DPE collectif voilà et
l'autre mesure importante qui nous
semble importante c'est que à partir du
moment où les copropriétaires ont fait
l'effort en assemblée générale de voter
ce qu'on appelle un plan pluriel de
travaux qui est une obligation par la
loi élan dans ces cas là on devrait
prendre acte du fait qu'il y a cette
bonne volonté de la part des
copropriétaires et surtout un engagement
financier et rendre les biens louables
l'engagement financier ça serait quoi de
la part des propriétaires avec une aide
de travaux précisément un calendrier de
travaux pour rénover un immeuble
combien de logements sont concernés au
niveau national et entourée le chiffre
qui est passage publié par la FNIM
aujourd'hui c'est environ un million 600
000 logements seraient dépassoirs
énergétiques c'est-à-dire GF et 500 000
logements seraient remis sur le marché
local de la suite à la difficulté de
louer j'ai fait un petit calcul sur le
parc des logements privés loués en
Indre-et-Loire enfin surtout métropole
pour être exact c'est 42000 si on fait
la même projection évidemment c'est
fictif on aurait 1800 logements qui
reviendrait sur le marché c'est
considérable donc il faut vraiment
trouver des solutions pour accompagner
les bailleurs